elon musk has revealed that if he
succeeds in buying twitter he will
reverse the social media giant's
decision to ban donald trump and
reinstate the former president's account
the prospective buyer who's the world's
richest person warned he believes
permanent bans should be extremely rare
as he attempts to push through his 35
billion pound deal
banning trump from twitter didn't end
trump's voice
it will amplify it
among the right and this is why it is
morally wrong and flat out stupid
joined now by bruce daisley the former
vice president of twitter
good idea or bad idea to reinstate
president trump
uh i feel like we're sort of in a modern
day version of like those greek fairy
stories that we used to hear that when
we used to hear that zeus or apollo did
incredible things now we're waiting to
see what the billionaires are deciding
for us on a daily basis um you know it's
worth reminding ourselves why trump got
banned from twitter he got banned
because in the midst of that january the
sixth insurrection after repeated
warnings and final warnings he was
really deliberately not trying to stop
the
violence he was posting things saying he
felt that the people invaded in the
capital were loyal to him and just
effectively he probably drove
i i worked here at the time he probably
drove the leadership of the organization
to the point where they had no choice
and so i think most people on january
the 7th would have said that the ban was
justified and most media accepted that
but i guess we've all got short memories
but should it be up to
billionaires like elon musk to decide
who we get to hear from exactly my point
yeah i think that you know in a
democratic society the idea that one
man's women and the change of ownership
could change the
the the way that these social platforms
impact is obviously it feels very
undemocratic you know billionaires whims
controlling media has always been
something that we've been subject to and
something we we've witnessed in in press
and in broadcast but you know now it's
coming to social platforms and the
danger is it just feels wholly
undemocratic so you know
broadly he was banned for repeatedly
going against the terms he was menacing
people threatening people
but ultimately it shouldn't be one
person's decision whether he comes back
but should social media i mean in
business be democratic it's
it's not part of the government is it
it's it's not part
of that kind of regulatory sphere it is
something that's an an independent
business why does it have to be
democratic
but there you go i'll let's leave that
as your final note but um
i think
but you know i think in a democratic
society the the opportunity to have uh
to have oversight over these incredibly
powerful tools is probably something of
a right you know one of the challenges
is that we're allowing and almost
deferring the the control of what we we
read and see we're allowing that to sit
broadly to the winner of who's got the
biggest pile of cash money uh
pile of cash so um look you know i i
think
i think most people would have said when
donald trump got suspended that he
deserved he'd reached a point where he
deserved that i recognized that
probably you know that is a
a subjective decision but it's a shame
that it will fall to one person um to
change that when probably collectively
there was agreement on it before
how then could you make
social media more democratic how could
it be more accountable given that of
course by its very nature it's something
which is truly global um it isn't
limited to one country which i imagine
would make it more straightforward to to
keep it within one set of rules yeah
absolutely i think in first instance
more accountability so quite often
technology companies shroud themselves
in secrecy you know almost like colonel
sanders original uh recipe they try and
say that their algorithm is complicated
and sophisticated and so the consequence
of that they avoid too much scrutiny but
my exposure i worked for eight years at
twitter my exposure is that if people
knew the amount of um the amount of
employees working on responding to to to
issues or if people knew the amount of
people working to keep
toxic tweets away from them if they if
they knew how small those teams were
then they would have an opinion on it
and my view is that every platform from
facebook to youtube to twitter
should have to publish the amount of
people they've got working responding to
customer inquiries responding to
if someone he's receiving abuse they
should know that the team responding to
that is only three people
i think if we knew those things and if
our politicians were able to to
uh know those things it would
fundamentally change the the dialogue
the discourse that takes place if we
knew the rules and the rules were
published then we could say okay we
don't believe those rules are strict
enough so we often see these things only
when they intrude into the news
premiership football is subjected to
racist abuse and the first thing we say
is how did this happen well if we knew
that it happened because there was a
small team uh the size of the
the uber passengers in a car in and
they're dealing with it in hungary if we
knew that all of those things were the
components they would say well now it's
obvious that that was going to happen
and i think if there was that degree
more transparency it would actually
improve our ability to to police these
things and hold them uh hold these
platforms accountable
did you make it all sound a little bit
sinister do you now on reflection
looking back as somebody who's worked
within it do you think it slightly is
no i mean i'm a big fan of how these
platforms can work but broadly you have
to understand that the business model of
silicon valley is it's very convenient
for silicon valley platforms to say look
we're going to allow free speech we're
going to allow these things to be
unfiltered because they're incredibly
cheap it's like opening a swimming pool
and saying we're not going to have
lifeguards it's much cheaper to do it
that way
and it's in the interest of the venture
capitalists who often are funding these
these businesses when they start up to
put in that very reduced basic model but
when it comes down to a platform that's
reaching 10 15 20 million people i think
we have a right to say okay i understand
that there was an entrepreneurial stage
where you were getting going but no we
expect a degree of accountability we
expect a degree that you're going to
operate within norms and i think we've
too often been carried by the the appeal
of innovation and entrepreneurs
and we've not necessarily
we're going to have to stop because
we're about to hit the break but thank
you very much bruce daisley former vp of
twitter
[Music]